now here is the video that we showed you
a couple of days because desantis has
just been knocking it out of the park
here's desantis a couple days ago
telling those university of south
florida students to take off their masks
you do not have to wear those masks i
mean please take it off honestly it's
not doing anything and we got to stop
with this code theater so you want to
wear it fine but this is this is
ridiculous
all right well it's good to be at usf
okay so what happened after that well
after that then everyone said desantis
there's a is a bully he forced the kids
to take off their mask he told him it
was their choice he didn't force anyone
to do anything you can even take you see
the kid taking it off and like the smile
on his face like oh i can breathe again
so desantis is really fighting the
machine right now now i want to contrast
that
to
new york governor kathy hoechel or as i
call her kathy c word
because as they start taking masks off
in new york at least in parts of new
york
she's very concerned that the masked
might now get bullied even though if
they were the ones bullying everyone for
the last two years we'll not have any
tolerance for people who are questioning
someone's own personal decision to do
what they want if people want to
continue wearing masks they're allowed
to continue wearing masks and i don't
want any issues related to that and i
want to be very clear on that we will
not stand for any bullying or
ostracization or harassment of an
individual or a business or anyone who
chooses to wear a mask
all right so this is totally
extraordinary and i'm not just talking
about her eyebrows and she's definitely
on the pelosi root whatever's going
there like what did these people do
like they're just trying to look evil
it's weird but what is she really saying
there it's actually pretty amazing she's
saying we will not tolerate any bullying
now first off these are the bullies
you kathy sieward you are the bully you
are the mandate bully you are the vaxxo
you are the people that have been
bullying everyone for the last two years
to do exactly what you want but also
what do you mean as the governor we will
not tolerate any bullying of kids or
people or businesses that want to wear
masks now i'm not for bullying
inherently everyone can make whatever
choice they want that's what i have
that's what i believe in it's what i've
pushed this entire time right but what
do you mean we will not tolerate it are
you going to arrest students who might
make fun of other students i mean were
is that what you're going to do are you
going to start arresting people who mock
people what do you mean we will not
tolerate it as a representative of the
state so that's what's going on in new
york and now let's throw back
to that tucker clip with ron desantis
related to uh bullying or and masks and
covet and the whole damn thing
well tucker none of the adults were
wearing masks and it seemed to me that
someone told those kids they had to do
it so i just wanted to make it very
clear they do not need to be doing it
obviously in florida it's a free state
you can do it but i think it's also
important to point out that there's no
reason to do it for for young and
healthy kids especially in the state of
florida we never had a mass mandate of
course but our guidance from our health
department is not to wear these cloth
masks and i think it needs to be said
because people have been lied to for two
years and so i was
i didn't want it to be thinking that
like they were told to do this by me
because i certainly wouldn't do that and
you know they talk about oh by letting
someone have a choice to take off their
mask and welcoming that choice that
that's somehow bullying tucker bullying
is locking kids out of school which they
did bullying is forcing kids to wear
masks for eight hours a day which they
did for two years and they're only
stopping now because the pollings change
bullying is kicking people out of work
because of vaccine mandates we fought
all of those policies in florida we
lifted people up and we liberated them
from local school boards and governments
that
that's my governor do you see what they
do they are the bullies they are the
hysterical authoritarians they're the
ones who have ruined so many people's
lives and broke these young people to
the point that even now
today you still see young healthy high
school kids wandering around in masks
because of the fear that these people
have put on so telling people hey you
don't have to wear the mask that's not
the bullying tactic they are the bullies
they do all the bad stuff and then they
call everyone else bad guys we have to
really understand what that is so that
we know how to behave better when it
happens and desantis really is becoming
a master of it